and um i guessed about it so i guess
we're going
so i'm gonna have dinner with my uncle
daley at cindy
it's gonna be ham i hope i hate him
i hate him i just
quick side thing here because i actually
had a discussion i i hate i hate him
i have to be specific when i say i hate
him i don't mind
ham in a sandwich like sliced cold ham
i like pork obviously i'm fat and i'm
cuban so obviously i like pork
you know but i don't
like just a hot ham
i'm i'm not i'm not a fan
i am not a fan of hot ham i just not
i don't again don't mind it in a
sandwich
have no issue with it like a cold you
know ham and a sandwich
but when when people have just like a
hot ham a hot ham dinner
i don't understand it okay i
don't i don't i don't like it i don't
want a hot
ham [ __ ] turkey turkey's fine
no issue with that pork butt you got it
pulled pork all day long most parts of
the pork
but a [ __ ] hot ham is [ __ ]
ridiculous
it's ridiculous
uh it's not it's not the hebrew me i
again i like pork so
bacon and all that stuff honey roasted
ham's even worse
don't [ __ ] sweeten up my ham i don't
need any of that [ __ ] it's [ __ ] i get
it
i understand people like ham i don't
like him
no [ __ ] thank you
there's so many better parts of the pork
i don't want [ __ ] ham
yeah i don't like hot ham i don't care
you can unsubscribe if you want i don't
like hot ham
no [ __ ] thank you
i don't like it i don't want it don't
give it to me
you don't sweeten up my ham i don't want
you to sweeten up my ham
you wouldn't download a pig would you
it's not funny um
yeah [ __ ] ham with a pineapple cut
out
[ __ ] you and your [ __ ] hot ham i
don't mind double dicks deviled eggs are
fine
see jj you're not you can't pin me down
you can't pin me down
you'll never pin me down um
ham sucks thank you because if he amp
sucks ham socks
pork is f i love pork i'm cuban nothing
better than pork
love the pork don't like ham anyone who
serves you a ham is your enemy
that's all i'm saying it's just you know
it's a simple
it's a simple point that i'm making okay
so you want to make sure everyone knows
my stance on him i thought it was
important that all of you knew
i hope the dogs or my cat my mom's cat
doesn't destroy the ham like because
what happened in the christmas story
they had to go out to eat yeah give
chris the story i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna rehash it [ __ ] terrible
movie
the chinese place yeah the chinese place
yeah that's the only one that was open
open christmas chinese food i know it
sucks if that's only places
that was open oh no i know one person
agrees and i don't think you're
outnumbered
you're all wrong about ham that's all
all of you were just wrong about him and
that's fine you could all live your life
being wrong about him
i ain't a judge you live your life
however you want
but you were 100 incorrect about him
that's all
the only place only okay
so um is there anything i was going to
say oh yeah
i hope i use oh cranberry sauce a
[ __ ]
thing you know i want to get through
these thomas videos but [ __ ] let's
talk about cranberry sauce for a second
you want to talk about [ __ ] terrible
[ __ ] are you
kidding me cranberry sauce is a goddamn
joke who
the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] likes cranberry
sauce
who's that for what the [ __ ] cranberry
sauce for
jj stop you're [ __ ] egging me on oh
[ __ ] you want two terrible things
together hey i got you a hot [ __ ] ham
here's some [ __ ] cranberry sauce if
cranberry was so
[ __ ] good why do you have to put 50
pounds of sugar in it to make it edible
huh think about that
i do hate sam i am very much so
cranberry sauce can also suck a dick
[ __ ] enough
[ __ ] [ __ ] cranberry sauce on a hot
ham what kind of [ __ ] poor people
food is that [ __ ]
why are fat people food because we've
eaten more food so we're better critics
of it
obviously
that's why i hope that answered your
question
one on man you've never come on my never
had peanut butter and cranberry sandwich
no i haven't
it sounds disgusting
[ __ ] [ __ ] cranberry sauce too
and by the way that whole cranberry
juice or urinary tract infection that's
a myth that doesn't work that's you look
it up that's a myth
so a big cramp let me tell you something
folks
big cranberry has been lying to you
big cranberry has been lying to you
it's it's like the people that sell kale
it's like the people that [ __ ] sell
kale
they nobody would eat cranberries in
their natural state
but they have all these [ __ ]
cranberries so what are they gonna do
they [ __ ] lie to you
and they tell you that cranberry ocean
spray is sugar water
you're not eating cranberry you're
eating sugar water
would drink green eggs and ham with a
box with a fox probably not
so no
i'm really sick big cranberry
big cranberry
has been lying to you
for years they've been lying to you
here's the advertising idea for canada
dry cranberry ginger ale
a blues thing cranberry in my ginger ale
is not too sweet oh yeah
new cranberry ginger ale it's green
and red did i say more yeah say a lot
more
why does it taste like garbage canada
dry cranberry ginger ale with less sugar
than most leading soft drinks it's less
sweet what a refreshing idea
we wish you a merry christmas and a less
sweet new year
see
this is the reason folks this you you
[ __ ] cranberry sauce loving [ __ ]
are the [ __ ] reason do you get that
the q or the [ __ ] reason that we
are sending so much money into pakistan
and all this foreign because
your lobbyists the cranberry lobby is
controlling your goddamn minds
don't let him lie to you
don't let them
lie to you
enough i'm back to thomas i'm not going
to get distracted
i've already gotten distracted that's a
lie i probably will don't get distracted
again
sister sierra likes the card and kaylee
cause i'm gonna tell her
i'm gonna give my cousin vincent hot
wheels instead of like the
stuff they didn't like give him hot
wheels
but not the track no the cars so i guess
we're going so i gotta go so
bye bye now look oh roy says ibs
understands how p works jj stoner good
point can't even poop right what would
he understand how to pp
hey i don't want to hear it jj [ __ ] a
diabetic [ __ ] alright you have no
[ __ ] right to tell anybody how to
live their life all right if you look at
ice cream your heart stops
so you could back the [ __ ] um you could
back the [ __ ] off my friend
i don't want to hear it from you
uh um anyway
telling me talking about me
i [ __ ] doubt it jj